the perfect childhood school is out
shoes are off you're sprinting across
the hot sandy beach smiling for no
apparent reason because back then you
didn't even need one did i mention
there's an orange cone on your head
where did it come from
why is it there what is the point do not
think too deeply about it there's no
room for symbolism in the summer there
is no use over analyzing the antics of
teenage youth it's just a cone and
you're just a kid doing things for no
other reason than that you want to
you're busy living doing your thing
responsibility is still years away such
a pretty picture we're painting isn't it
but this is scp explained so of course
by now you figured out this is all a
misdirection didn't you
well here it comes watch closely look at
you run moving towards nothing as if it
means everything look at that smile the
wind whipping through the gap in your
teeth soak it in in 20 years your face
muscles will have forgotten the movement
look at you live
yes go on soak it in you will be chasing
this feeling your whole life while
moving further and further away from it
depressing isn't it we think so too but
here is the silver lining something
you'd be wise to celebrate at least you
have this moment to look back on the
memory is with you forever not everyone
is so lucky not everyone had a good
childhood furthermore not everyone even
has a childhood at all
some live beyond the expectations of age
imagine a 14 year old forced to be 40.
that's not to say they have to pay taxes
or can run for senate no this level of
forced maturity that i'm speaking of
transcends the scope of average
adulthood so let's not imagine a kid
going through the mundane life of a
cubicle junkie filing papers pretending
to work and answering phone calls
instead let's do this imagine a kid
going to war imagine a kid carrying out
stealth assassination missions imagine a
kid being locked in containment living
with little human interaction and
freedom this is all to say imagine a kid
not being a kid at all
now this is more like an scp explained
this is the sad story of someone who had
to say goodbye to the joys of
adolescence earlier than anyone ever
should have to in fact they didn't even
get to say goodbye at all
this is the story of scp-105
now to be clear
scp-105 is not a bloodthirsty demon
living in the shadows it is not an
unsquishable spider dancing across your
hardwood floor mocking the soles of your
shoes as they stomp down with no success
it is not a grand piano in a hotel lobby
absorbing the dna of all who touches its
keys and it is not a freezer that tempts
late night snackers to reach deeper and
deeper towards an ever elusive hot fudge
sundae until they are sucked in frozen
solid sold for millions and displayed as
decorative ice sculptures atop the
center of punch bowls at parties for
rich politicians
no we'll just have to get to those later
on on a different day because
scp-105 is just
how do i put this a girl yes a small
unremarkable looking girl at the time of
acquisition she was just 1.5 meters tall
and weighed 50 kilograms even those of
you listening with little to no
instinctual senses for converting meters
and kilograms to feet and pounds can
still understand this is no frightful
giant we're talking about lining up a
class by height she'd blend in somewhere
toward the middle and if you look even
closer beyond the shallow surface of
measurements and toward the details of
her face even still you won't find a
single freckle to fear
scp-105 has blue eyes and blonde hair
nothing coastal californians haven't
seen a million times over just this
monday formerly known as iris thompson
scp-105 has no discernible oddities if
you saw her jumping rope you wouldn't
point and stare if you saw her at the
park playing with your children you
wouldn't pull them away and squeeze them
tight if you saw her walking toward you
on a sidewalk you wouldn't turn around
and run away in the other direction by
herself scp-105 is not too different
from anyone else no matter how close we
zoom in on her appearance personality or
her tendencies there is nothing to see
that triggers alarms if you ask her to
spit fire she won't if you conduct a lab
experiment where she has to find the
exit of a maze using only her sense of
smell she will get lost and fail this is
all to say if you look too closely
through the microscope at scp-105
you might miss her anomalous abilities
instead you'd be better off taking a
step back and just watching her live her
life and that is all that she wanted to
do
live her life is that so much to ask the
first thing you will notice is that she
isn't alone and like in any good buddy
buddy film her counterpart reveals more
to her character so who is standing by
her side who is the co-star of this film
that pushes our protagonist into the
foundation spotlight well it's no person
at all it's a camera her camera
scp-105-b
is a polaroid one step express
manufactured in 1982.
it does not appear to have any out of
the ordinary physical characteristics
and appears to be for all intents and
purposes a normal polaroid camera
operating as expected for all persons
aside from scp-105
when you point it at a subject they
don't get sucked into the lens the flash
can't blind an army of soldiers when you
say cheese it doesn't shoot out a brick
of cheddar the camera is nothing more
than a camera that is until it's in the
hands of iris thompson what's more
unique than the camera itself are the
photographs it produces when scp-105
holds a photograph taken by scp-105-b
the picture changes from a still shot to
that of a real-time image of the person
location
or object photographed regardless of the
subject of the photograph the image will
convert itself into what appears to be a
handheld live stream of whatever was
pictured imagine a photograph of a
waterfall if held by
scp-105 you do not just see the image of
a waterfall but you will physically see
the water falling splashing down onto
the rocks below it is similar to holding
your cell phone and watching a gif
however instead of just watching iris is
able to interact with it in a way beyond
any technology has ever allowed
scp-105 is then able to move her arm
through and into the photograph and
manipulate objects within reach of the
original point at which the photograph
was first taken yes you heard me right
scp-105-2 doesn't just offer iris quick
prints of memories it gives her much
more granting her access to a new
dimension although this is clearly a
unique situation for iris it doesn't
mean that iris is the only one affected
by this anomaly when she engages with
the photographs it actually affects the
world attached to them that is to say
there are consequences to her actions
every photograph she has ever taken is
essentially a portal to a world of
problems witnesses who have been on the
other side of the photograph while
scp-105 was manipulating it reported
seeing her hand reaching out from an
invisible portal and carrying on
whatever actions she pleases once her
arm is inside the photograph she has the
freedom to control the image as she
wishes this ability has obvious benefits
for anyone imagine being able to carry
around with you a photograph of your
oven then whenever you get that paranoid
feeling that you forgot to turn it off
you can reach into the polaroid and turn
the dial how you please but the peace of
mind is just a small benefit of this
power and it's easy to assume that
anyone would be tempted to use their
abilities for far more than just
controlling at-home kitchen appliances
while on vacation the foundation
specifically concerns itself with bigger
more ambitious uses of anomalous power
and the power in this case wasn't just
in the camera while 105-b helps iris use
her powers most efficiently she is still
able to manipulate objects through
photographs taken by other cameras
though not quite as well as when she's
using her favorite camera noting that
105-b and the photographs taken by said
camera have no unusual properties when
used by any other person except for
scp-105
it was clear to the foundation who the
greater anomaly in the situation really
was the tool wasn't of their interest
but rather the person wielding it but
how did this all come to their attention
is the foundation really investigating
the life of a girl playing with a camera
in her bedroom well some moments are
just too big to be bound by privacy
scp-105 was brought to the forefront of
the foundation's attention shortly after
the murder of her boyfriend promptly
after his death the police investigated
the scene and looked for answers and
when looking for answers they started
conjuring up questions one of which put
iris at the center of their search where
were you her response wasn't so
straightforward she wasn't there but
then she was the police pressed further
not understanding
scp-105 explained that she was at home
but once she learned of his death she
hurried over to him this left the police
even more suspicious as there was no way
she could have been informed of the
murder by an outside source she must
have been there all along seeing the
skepticism in their faces
scp-105 scrambled for an explanation she
took a deep breath and got her story
straight she claimed to have been on the
phone with her boyfriend at the time of
the violent attack and once she heard
the commotion it prompted her to hurry
over to his location where she saw him
dead this excuse made logical sense and
so the police dropped their suspicion
after all iris was just a small innocent
teenager however just as quickly as the
police move on from iris they returned
to her this time with tangible proof of
their doubts the telephone records did
not correspond to her story she was
never on the phone with her boyfriend
that night it was then that scp-105 had
to confess she informed her lawyer that
she had in fact been there for the
murder well not there but kind of there
she explained how she witnessed the
murder through a photograph she had
taken with her boyfriend several days
prior the attorney in question
disregarded the story and recommended
that the subject plead guilty iris
however refused to do so she was
sticking to her truth no matter how
crazy it made her seem she went forward
and told her story in court it was met
with derision the judge and the jury
didn't even entertain the possibility of
any of it being true iris was flustered
she was a young teenage girl fighting
for her freedom her only weapon being
the truth but the room wasn't
participating in her reality they
dismissed her as crazy and so when iris
offered to demonstrate her ability it
was the last straw the judge wouldn't
allow iris to waste any more of anyone's
time she was sentenced to a psychiatric
ward iris was determined to get out of
there she knew she didn't belong luckily
someone else knew too that she didn't
belong and because of this in a matter
of days she was out of there but home
wasn't where she was heading no it
wasn't mom and dad picking her up from
the psychiatric ward but rather the
foundation breaking her out stealing her
for themselves and bringing her to site
17. there at site 17 foundation
personnel began their mission which
started with trying to convince
scp-105 that they were on her side they
began by retrieving
scp-105-b from scp-105's home and
replacing it with an identical model
only then to give it to her under the
lie that it was the original the lies
wouldn't stop just there they'd continue
to pour over her reality until it was
impossible for her to recognize one from
the other
scp-105's parents was informed that she
was killed during the botched escape of
another patient while both were in the
custody of a psychiatric care facility
in truth though the foundation wants
nothing more than to keep
scp-105 alive however they are not
concerned about the quality of her
living iris was a tool for the
foundation she was an asset she was a
secret weapon she had powers they could
have only dreamed of only now
they existed but before shooting their
shiny new weapon they needed to learn
how to use it properly but with what
manual how do you learn how to use
another human well having seen enough
marvel movies they knew they would be
better equipped with knowledge if they
understood her origin story so they
began questioning iris trying to get to
the root cause of her anomalous aptitude
she was either 10 or 11. she remembers
because she was looking at a picture of
the ocean and she noticed that the waves
began moving her parents said that she
just had an overactive imagination when
she first was able to move objects in
the photos she was 11 12 maybe her
family took a trip to the grand canyon
she looked through the photo album after
they got home and she brushed her hand
up against one by accident when she did
she pushed a rock over the edge falling
into the canyon she could actually hear
it clatter on the way down she became
fascinated with photography after that
most of the time it didn't work with
photographs she took but her parents got
her a polaroid one step express camera
that she'd been begging them for since
christmas after she got the camera the
photos got easier to interact with after
hearing her story the researchers made
her an offer she'd be allowed certain
freedoms if she agreed to use her powers
to do them a few favors she could at
least in some capacity act her age
socialize and do things a girl her grade
would normally do but in exchange she
had to first do things that nobody any
age should ever have to do
iris agreed and it was in this agreement
that we see just how desperate she was
during her childhood she was willing to
risk everything for something as small
as a quick conversation with a guard
five minutes of jump rope or simply a
few minutes spent under the sun she was
assigned to be part of mobile task force
omega 7 to carry out a wide range of
missions and if the fate of the first
humanoid scp recruited to mobile task
force omega 7 was any indication how
this might play out iris was in a lot of
trouble the pandora's box initiative had
a history of failure their previous
efforts under team able ended in the
death of absolutely everyone however
team iris began on a more hopeful note
they carried out different missions than
team able instead of violent attacks
their primary missions were
reconnaissance and intelligence
gathering however just because there
were no swords and blood drawn the
missions were not so harmless despite
team iris carrying out over 20 jobs in
cooperation with the beau commission
swiftly and without incident their
streak eventually had to come to an end
the first disciplinary incident for
scp-105 involved the escalation of team
iris missions from reconnaissance to
assassinations yes this teenage girl
with not a violent bone in her body was
tasked to kill note that her only power
is that of manipulating photos in her
mind this is nothing more than a party
trick it was a gift she was born with
and she was always aware that it was
unique but never did she expect it to be
a curse she liked being able to
straighten books and photographs of
libraries she liked being able to read
into photos and hug her teddy bear that
she no longer has she liked being able
to help heal and embrace history not
alter it
scp-105 violently opposed the use of her
abilities to carry out assassinations
they wanted her to murder people and
like any girl of her nature would she
resisted but they kept pressing while
some teenage girls are pressured by
parents to play sports they don't
particularly care for this one was
pressured to kill during these events
scp-105 became emotionally distressed
and attempted to deceive foundation
personnel into believing that her
anomalous traits had disappeared she
claimed that she couldn't carry out the
missions anymore her doctor submitted a
report recommending that scp-105 be
reclassified as neutralized undergo
amnestic treatment and be released to
the public with regular monitoring after
further investigation the foundation
realized the doctor was prioritizing
scp-105's emotional state over the goals
of the foundation they had built a
friendship he was the one telling her to
pretend not to have powers anymore this
was all found out thus his
recommendation to release iris was
denied with nothing to lose at that
point the doctor even helped iris trying
to escape the foundation's custody but
this failed she was captured and the
doctor was promptly discharged at that
point iris had to start over again to
regain the trust of the foundation and
yet another compromise she
redemonstrated her anomalous abilities
in exchange for the restoration of
limited privileges nothing more than
occasionally being allowed to jump rope
getting a lollipop every thursday and
being informed of the recent trends on
tick-tock and so this is where we know
her to be continuously making sacrifices
in exchange for tiny teaspoons of
teenage life all the while she is
growing older and older unfulfilled by
the years she passes and so while it is
easy to look back on our childhood with
lust and longing at least it was there
and is still there now
safely stored in our memory stored in
the protection of the past for iris this
is not so her childhood is both behind
her and in front of her it is something
she moved on from too quickly and it is
a future she fights for every day even
when she is 97 grey decrepit and on her
deathbed she will be sacrificing her
freedoms to feel 15. and so we have to
wonder is scp-105 a danger to anyone at
all i leave you with a question are we
more likely to be attacked by a dog or
the master holding its leash now go
check out
scp-053 young girl and scp-3082
neverland's lost boys and girls for more
peculiar anomalous children